Loras isn't the Queen's gown magnificent a
fabric the embroidery the metalwork I've never
seen anything like it I find a bit of armor
quite useful once you become green perhaps
before Marja does great deal of work with a
poor back in Highgarden the lowest among us
are no different from the highest if you give
them a chance and approach them with an open
heart an open heart is what you'll get in flea
bottom if you're not careful my dear I'm glad
house Tyrell has been able to help in this
regard they tell me 100 wagons arrive daily
now from the reach wheat barley apples we've
had a blessed harvest and of course it's our
duty to assist the capital in time of need
I'm sure she knows what she's doing I'm sure
she does would you like to see where the
last Targaryens are buried are you sure
lady Margaery doesn't find all this bit macabre
oh no it's quite all right your grace I'd love
to see their tombs really it's like taking
a walk through history you look radiant your
grace radiant why radiant it's the word that
came to mind we're going to be sisters soon
if you have a call me sister again
I'll have you strangled in your sleep
King Joffrey has decreed that the leftovers
from our feast be given to the poorest in
his City leave this wedding right now
go to the kitchens and instruct them
that all the leftovers from the feast will
be brought to the kennels your grace Queen
Margaery Queen they were just telling you
and leftovers will feed the dogs who you were
he sits the throne like he was born to it yes
he wasn't though was he he's still mourn for
Joffrey he was my husband I came he would have
been your nightmare you're still interested in
being Queen I take it no after all this
happened we may be faced with an alarming
number of weddings soon hmm I won't even
know what to call you sister Oh mother hmm
but just being in his presence was enough
to make it so clear just how formidable a
person you were dealing with mother welcome I'm
glad to hear you ecstatic I really am exhausted
to be honest but what could I expect he is
half lion half stag the Queen Mother will be
a queen grandmother soon happy and lovely day
[Music] and according to the law of the seven
now the Kings nor Queens are exempt from
testimony at a holy inquest I am The Queen
[Music]